le château de chamerolles près de sur
bois propose une promenade des parfums
rose jasmin iris bergamote eu mais pour
comprendre très loin d odeur d'humidité
respirer dans certains châteaux
ici le guide vous mène par le bout du
nez attendrissant quoi
je ne suis pas mais ça sent pas bon que
je découvre c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup
de terminologie qui est en lien avec la
musique
et donc voilà donc du coup j'ai déjà le
vocabulaire et le fait qu'on compose sur
trois types de deux notes et de te
clavier la référence alors nous voilà
c'est
très musical autre particularité de
chamerolles une situation géographique
surprenante dans la malle de lois
relatives et beaucoup de sociétés qui
étaient bien servir à la création du
personnage que ce soit de la sérigraphie
sur des flacons ou justement dans la
fabrication ou d'embouteillage et donc
voila c'était une découverte une
dernière donc d'autant plus intéressant
on a premièrement les notes de tête
les notes de cars et les notes de fond
en retard sur les italiens les français
ont longtemps utilisé des pommades des
onguents avant de distiller les fleurs
c'est grâce à rené le florentin le
parfumeur de catherine de médicis que le
parfum devient liquide en france à cette
époque là ce n'était pas encore tout à
fait le cas
et généralement quand une nouvelle reine
arrive à la cour de france ce qu'on fait
c'est pour la copie tout simplement
et donc c'est à partir de ce moment là
que les aristocrates et les gens de la
cour de france vont commencer à se
parfumer cette visite c'est aussi
l'occasion d'apprendre que le roi de
pologne aurait été séduit par sa voisine
la reine de hongrie alors âgé de 70 ans
grâce à un subtil parfum de romarin
sauge marjolaine et d'autres vies et ça
en 1380